[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD CAPPIELLO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DRAW [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL.
HUESO --
TALA [inaudible]
JACKSON JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE MORNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROUGH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
TURN [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY KELSEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LET IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BUYER CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
RUBIO.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
FATHER MOTHER GODS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE
DURING THE HARD AND MEAN DAYS.
FOR THEN WE HAVE YOU TOLEAN
UPON.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE
DURING THE BRIGHT AND SUNNY DAYS.
FOR THEN WE CAN SHARE BASS WHICH
WE HAVE WITH THOSE WHO HAVE LESS.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENCE
DURING THE HOLY DAYS. FOR THEN
WE'RE ABLE TO CELEBRATE TO YOU
AND OUR FAMILIES AND OUR FRIENDS.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE NO VOICE WE
ASK YOU TO SPEAK. FOR THOSE WHO
FEEL UNWORTHY WE ASK YOU TO POUR
OUT YOUR LOVE.
AND WATERFALLS OF TENDERNESS.
FOR THOSE WHO LIVE IN PAIN.
WE ASK YOU TO BAIT THEM AND THE
RIVER OF YOUR HEALING. FOR THOSE
WHO ARE LONELY WE ASK YOU TO
KEEP THEM COMPANY. FOR THOSE WHO
ARE DEPRESSED WE ASK YOU TO
SHOWER UPON THEM THE LIGHTS OF
HOPE [inaudible]
DEAR CREATOR.
YOU THE BORDER LOS CA OF
SUBSTANCE.
WE ASK YOU TO GIVE TO ALL THE
WORLD'S.
THAT'S RICH THREE MOST NEEDS
PEAS.
AND I APOLOGIZE THAT I FORGOT TO
SAY THIS IS A POEM BY MAYA
ANGELOU [inaudible]
A MAN.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME.
I PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD.
WITH LIBERTY.
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. FOR
ALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO START WITH PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR SENATOR GALGIANI I
BELIEVE YOU HAD A PRIVILEGE OF
THE FLOOR.
SENATOR GALGIANI AT THE PRO
TEM'S DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES TO DAMN PROUD TO
PRESENT THIS RESOLUTION THAT
RECOGNIZES THE HARD WORK OF A
GROUP OF EXCEPTIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE TRACE TASK FORCE.
THE TAX RECOVERY AND CRIMINAL
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCE ALSO
KNOWN AS TRACE IS COMPRISED OF
INVESTIGATORS AND SPECIAL AGENTS
FROM MULTIPLE AGENCIES WORKING
TOGETHER TO INVESTIGATE
PROSECUTE.
AND RECOVER REVENUE LOSS TO THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY THIS TASK
FORCE WAS PUT INTO STATUTE BY
THIS BODY.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT THE STATE'S
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY IS AS LARGE
AS A HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
AS A RESULT THE STATE LOSES AN
ESTIMATED EIGHT POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN CORPORATE
PERSONAL AND SALES AND USE TAXES
EACH YEAR.
AN AMOUNT THAT IS ACTUALLY THE
EQUIVALENT THESE DEDICATED
AGENTS PLAY A VITAL ROLE
COMBATING THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS
OF THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY SUCH
AS LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS.
UNFAIR COMPETITION AND LOST TAX
REVENUE HERE TODAY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WE HAVE
JAMES DISCLOSE.
SUSAN GORSUCH SCOTT BACHMAN
PETER WALLED MATT MORE.
AND FROM THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT WE HAVE
OUR LENA MY TRIVET.
FROM THE HOMELAND SECURITY
INVESTIGATION WE HAVE JOSE --
TELE.
ROBBY CAN WOULD WITH THE IRS AND
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION WE
HAVE TOM SCHMIDT.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE RISE AND JOIN
ME IN RECOGNIZING THEIR HARD
WORK AND EFFORTS.
WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
YOU SENATOR GALGIANI
MEMBERS WERE STILL UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND WHEN
I MOVED TO SENATOR HILL AND
BRADFORD FOR OUR NEXT PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOOR [inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
WE HAVE SEVERAL PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR AND THE FOLKS ARE NOT
HERE YET IS THERE ANYONE WHO IS
NOT ON MY LIST THAT HAS A
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR.
SEEING NONE WE WILL WAIT A
MOMENT
.
PRESIDENT MAY I SENATOR HILL OF
THE PRO TENDS TO US THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT AND
IT'S AN HONOR TO INTRODUCE TO
YOU TODAY.
STANFORD UNIVERSITY HISTORIAN DR
CLAIBORNE CARS.
AND FOR MANY OF YOU WHO HAVE
READ A LOT OR KNOWN OF THE WORK
OF DR MARTIN LUTHER KING.
IT'S BECAUSE OF DR CARSON THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW.
HE HAS DEVOTED MOST OF HIS
PROFESSIONAL LIFE IN THE STUDY
OF DR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
AND THE MOVEMENTS KING INSPIRED.
SINCE RECEIVING HIS DOCTORATE
FROM UCLA IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE DR CARSON HAS TAUGHT AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
WHERE HE IS NOW THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR CENTENNIAL
PROFESSOR OF HISTORY?
AND RONNIE LOTT FOUNDING
DIRECTOR OF THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION INSTITUTE.
IN NINETEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
KERETA SCOTT KING INVITED DR
CARSON TO DIRECT A LONG TERM
PROJECT. TO EDIT AND PUBLISH AN
AUTHORITARIAN AUTHORITATIVE
EDITION OF KING SPEECHES SERMONS
CORRESPONDENCE PUBLICATIONS AND
UNPUBLISHED WRITINGS.
UNDER DR CARSON'S DIRECTION THE
KING PAPERS PRJECT HAS PRODUCED
SEVEN VOLUMES OF THE PAPER'S OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE HE
FOUNDED THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
INSTITUTE. TO REALLY TO AND DAL
IN IT END EXPAND THE WORK THEY
STARTED EARLIER OF KING'S PAPERS
THE KING'S PAPERS PROJECT.
AND SO WHAT YOU.
DON'T KNOW ABOUT DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR YOU CAN LEARN.
BY VISITING THE INSTITUTE AT
STANFORD BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
WHICH YOU DON'T KNOW.
INTO YOU SEE WHAT'S AVAILABLE
AND THE TREMENDOUS WORK AND
SCHOLARSHIP OF DR CARSON UNDER
THE DIRECTION IN HIS DIRECTION
THE KING PAPERS PROJECT.
HAS PRODUCED SEVEN VOLUMES OF A
DEFINITIVE COMPREHENSIVE
ADDITION OF KINGS PUBLISHED AND
UNPUBLISHED WRITINGS ALONG WITH
THE PAPERS PROJECT THE
INSTITUTE'S ENTERPRISES INCLUDE
WRITING A BIOGRAPHY OF KING.
AND PROVIDING EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES FOR STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS.
DR CARSON ALSO SERVED AS SENIOR
ADVISER FOR VISION SERIES ON THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT OUR EYES
ON THE PRIZE.
IN ADDITION HE HAS PARTICIPATED
IN THE MAKING OF NUMEROUS OTHER
DOCUMENTARIES INCLUDING.
FREEDOM ON MY MIND FOR NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR WHICH WAS NOMINATED
FOR AN OSCAR.
THE AUDIO VERSION OF DR CARSON'S
ADDITION OF THE AUTOBIOGRAPHY OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR WON A
GRAMMY AWARD.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND DR CARSON THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO YOUR
DEDICATION.
AND THE WONDERFUL WORK TO DO YOU
HAVE GIVEN TO ALL OF US OF THE
WORKS OF DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
TO CALIFORNIA AND TO THE WORLD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
BRADFORD.
THANK YOU SENATOR HILL CENTER
BRADFORD AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR HILL FOR THIS
GREATER REDUCTION FOR DR CARSON
IS CONTRIBUTION TO MUCH OF WHAT
I HAD TO SAY.
OBSCENITY --
CLEARLY --
ELABORATED ON AS TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE WORK OF DR
CARSON AND WHAT IT MEANS TO US
AS SOCIETY AS YOU STATED THE
KING IT'S A TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
THOUSANDS OF DOCUMENTS
PHOTOGRAPHS.
AND PUBLICATIONS ABOUT THE
MODERN AFTER FOR MISSION OVER
THREE HUNDRED CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT FIGURES EVENTS AND
ORGANIZATIONS IT ALSO OFFERS A
DETAILED DATED A CHRONOLOGICAL
LEE.
OF KING'S LIFE DRAWN FROM THE
VOLUMES IN THE VOLUMES --
THE INSTITUTE FOCUSES ON THE
COMPLETION OF A DEFINITIVE MULTI
VOLUME ADDITION OF PAPERS OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING --
A DELIBERATION --
CURRICULUM EDUCATION INITIATIVE
A SCHOLAR WRITER IN RESIDENCE --
PROGRAM AND THE KINGS CONFERENCE
AND SAID SYMPOSIUMS AS WELL AS
OTHER PUBLIC EVENTS DESIGNED TO
ENHANCE UNDERSTANDING OF DR
KING'S LIFE IDEALS AND LEGACY.
AND IF I MAY AMOUNT OF PRESENT I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO READ.
ONE ABSURD FROM --
MARGE DREAMS DR CARSON'S BOOK
AND IT'S SIMPLY STATE THAT MARCH.
THANK YOU MARCH GLOBAL
HISTORICAL VISION LET ME TO SEE
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN FREEDOM
STRUGGLE STRUGGLE WITH ONLY ONE
ASPECT TO WHAT I HAVE TO COME TO
SEE AS AMERICA'S GREATEST
FREEDOM STRUGGLE.
DURING THE PAST TWO AND A HALF
CENTURIES A MAJORITY OF HUMANITY
OVERCAME MAJOR SAYS SYSTEMS OF
OPPRESSION NOTABLY INHERITED
FORMS OF STATUS BASED ON CLASS
RACE AND GENDER.
THE TRANSFORMATION OF THE
WORLD'S PEASANTS AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS INTO.
A SAID THE CENTER HAS BEEN THE
MOST IMPORTANT ACHIEVEMENT OF
MODERN AGE I'VE LEARNED TO
APPRECIATE THE TRANSFORMATION
WAS ACCOMPLISHED NOT ONLY
THROUGH FREEDOM STRUGGLES BUT
ALSO THROUGH THE MASS MIGRATION
THAT BROUGHT.
MY PARENTS OUT OF THE SOUTH TO
GREATER OPPORTUNITIES ELSEWHERE.
THIS GREAT TRANSFORMATION STILL
CONTAIN REYES ORIENT OR IN OR
ORIENTATIONS WITH EXTRA.
EXTEMPORANEOUS.
VISIONS OF A DREAM THAT HE WOULD
NEVER SEE. FOR FIELD AND A
PROMISE OF A LAND THAT HE WOULD
NEVER REACH.
HIS DREAM AND HIS VISION OF A
PROMISED LAND WERE ROOTED AND
SELF EVIDENT TRUTHS.
THAT JUSTIFIED THE AMERICAN
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE AND
IN THE FAITH BASED TRUCE OF
RELIGIOUS SCRIPTURE.
HIS FINAL SPEECH IN MEMPHIS WAS
MEANT FOR ALL HUMAN BEINGS
SEEKING TO BREAK FREE OF THE
IMPRESSION OTHER PRESS OF FORCES.
THAT CONSTRAIN THEIR LIVES THEIR
FREEDOM IN THEIR PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS.
UNDERSTANDING THE EXTENT TO
WHICH MARTIN'S VISION HAD
EXPANDED BY THE END OF HIS LIFE
I COULD SEE THAT THAT DREAM
STILL INDOORS IN THE FREEDOM
STRUGGLES OF OUR TIME.
AND IN ALL FUTURE FREEDOM
STRUGGLES WE CAN IMAGINE HIM
SPEAKING OF THE DAY WHEN FREEDOM
MORE RAIN IN EVERY VILLAGE AND
EVERY HAMLET.
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AND THEREBY
SPEED UP TO DAY ONE ALL GOD'S
CHILDREN ALL RACES WILL BE ABLE
TO JOIN HANDS AND SING IN THE
WORDS OF THAT GREAT NEGRO
SPIRITUAL FREE AT LAST FREE ALL
*.
GOD ALMIGHTY WERE FREE AT LAST
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD DR
CARSON WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE
MEMBERS WE ARE
STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO
SENATOR BELL.
SENATOR BELL AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS --
I RISE TO RECOGNIZE THE PRISON
ARTS COLLECTIVE IN ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION.
ON THERE ARE COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS PROVIDING ARTS IN REAL
WELL TAILORED PROGRAMS. TO
THOUSANDS OF INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA --
ARE P. A C. IS BASED IN --
CALIFORNIA STATE.
ST BERNARD YOU KNOW --
AND IS THE ONLY --
RECEIVE BASED ARTS.
IN CORRECTIONS PROGRAM.
IS MADE UP OF TALENTED ARTISTS
INTERNS UNIVERSITY FACULTY.
WHO PROVIDE TEACHER TRAINING IN
ARTS PROGRAMS?
AT NOW EIGHT CORRECTIONAL
INSTITUTIONS.
THEY'RE GOING TO PLANT THEIR
GOING TO TWELVE BY NEXT YEAR --
THEY HAVE AN ART EXHIBITION ON
DISPLAY NEXT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
WHERE WE WILL SEE AMAZING
ARTWORK BY OUR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS?
NOW AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IS A
SUPPORT NETWORK. FOR AN COMPOSED
BY INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DEVOTED TO CHANGING LIVES.
AND THE LVES THEIR LIVES AND
THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
BY VISITING CORRECTIONAL
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE STATE
PROVIDING REAL BILL TATUM
PROGRAMS.
POSTING POLICY WORKSHOPS.
IN THEIR CARS RATED AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION DEVELOP THE HOPE AND
REDEMPTION TEAM OFFERING. THREE
SUPPORT WORKSHOPS.
INCLUDING CRIMINALS AND GANG
MEMBERS AN OMINOUS.
BOARD PAROLE HEARING PREPARATION
RELAPSE PREVENTION.
YOUTH OFFENDER PROGRAM MENTORING.
WHICH IS NOW SERVES MORE THAN
TWO THOUSAND INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND SEVEN PRISONS
I'D LIKE YOU TO JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING --
AND THANKING.
OUR PRISONS ARTS COLLECTIVE IN
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION --
FURTHER DEDICATIONS --
TO CHANGING LIVES OF THOSE
INCARCERATED THROUGH PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE HOPE SELF AWARENESS.
AND EMPATHY CONGRADULATIONS WE
HAVE WITH US.
ANY BUCKLEY THE FOUNDER OF THE
PRISONS ARTS --
COALITION.
AND DIRECTOR MARK TAYLOR --
FORMER PARTICIPARON AN INTERN
AND SAM LEWIS --
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
OTHER MEMBERS IN THE GALLEY
INCLUDING YOUNG MAN THAT JUST
CELEBRATED HIS THIRTIETH
BIRTHDAY.
AND THEY USE UP THERE WHERE IS
THE OTHER AREAS HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
AND WOULD LIKE TO CONGRATULATE
THIS ORGANIZATION FOR THE FINE
WORK IN OUR IN OUR STATE --
FACILITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BELL.
SENATOR NIELSEN ON THIS ISSUE
YES PLEASE PROCEED.
ON THIS ISSUE AND I WANT.
TO LEND MY SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGEMENT TO THIS INITIATIVE.
AS ONE WHO'S LOOKED AT UP FRONT
PERSONAL IN MY MANY YEARS AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF PRISON TERMS.
AND I WAS ABLE TO FOR ABOUT FOUR
YEARS AGO THREE AND FOUR YEARS
AGO WORK WITH THEN --
CHAIRMAN OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
MARK LENO. TO GET FUNDING
RESTORED FOR ARCHING CORRECTIONS.
THAT USED TO BE A FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM IN THE ARTS
COUNCIL THEY EVEN HAD A MAN WORK
THERE.
THE SUPPORTED THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM.
AND THE MY WIFE LATER WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL AND THEY GOT TO ENJOY.
REACTIVATING THE EFFORTS OF THAT
MAN LIAISON WITH LIAISING WITH
THE VARIOUS INSTITUTIONS AND CDC
ARE THAT WE'RE DOING ARCH AND
CORRECTION.
AND I CAN TELL YOU'RE FROM THE
THOUSANDS OF INMATES THAT I'VE
INTERVIEWED DISCUSSED IN AND
LIFE HISTORIES I'VE READ ABOUT.
HOW THERAPEUTIC ART CAN BE?
IN THAT PARTICULAR REALM.
THERE'S HEATING THAT OCCURS
THROUGH ART.
AND GIFTS THAT THEY GIVE TO
OTHERS THROUGH THEIR ART THAT
OTHER PEOPLE GET TO ENJOY.
I CERTAINLY DO ENDORSE.
THIS PROGRAM.
AND THEIR EFFORTS FIGURES --
NIELSEN SENATOR GALGIANI.
THANK YOU I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROGRAM AND FOR A COUPLE
OF YEARS I HAD AND MANY OF US
ENJOYED IT AND TO THIS DAY IT
STILL HANGS IN MY OFFICE WHERE
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO ENJOY AND
APPRECIATE THE ARTWORK --
SO THANK YOU AGAIN AND IF YOU
CAN ARE ABLE TO STAY UST
ANOTHER MOMENT PASS THIS PICTURE.
I HAVE THE FOR THE ARTWORK
COMING DOWN AND WE CAN TAKE
ANOTHER PHOTO WITH THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR GALGIANI THANK
YOU SENATOR BILL AND WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE TO
THE PRISON ARTS COLLECTIVE
WE'RE
STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO ALLEN
[inaudible]
SENATOR AL THAMES DESK.
MEMBERS I'M I ALSO WANTED TO
CHIME IN IN IN SUPPORT FOR THIS
EXTRAORDINAY ARTS IN
CORRECTIONS PROGRAM --
AT THAT AYE AYE AYE CHANCE TO
SEE THEIR ART EXHIBIT DOWN BY
OUTSIDE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND I JUST ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY
TO GO CHECK IT OUT I KNOW NUMBER
MEMBERS ARE GONNA BE GOING. TO
ALIVE -- IN
A COUPLE WEEKS TO LEARN ABOUT
SOME OF THE INTERESTING AND EVER
SERVICE PROGRAMS THAT ARE GOING
ON WITH OUR CORRECTIONS SYSTEM
BUT THIS IS.
A VERY SPECIAL ONE I'M
INTRODUCING SOME FOLKS IN MY
CAPACITY AS CHAIRMAN OF OUR
JOINT COMMITTEE ARTS IN AS A AS
A FRIEND OF OF THIS GOOD MAN
HERE MIKHAIL LEE WAS SERVED.
IN AN IMPORTANT LEADERSHIP ROLE
IN THE COMPANY TO FIGHT SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR A LONG LONG TIME
AND I HI MAKE THIS PRESENTATION --
IN CONJUNCTION WITH OUR GREAT
CENTER FROM CONSTANT AND
GUARDINO --
CENTER BRADFORD --
SO THIS IS THIS IS THIS IS THE
HIGHWAY A VERY VERY SPECIAL
PARTNERSHIP.
THAT EXISTS BETWEEN --
AN IMPORTANT EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND IMPORTANT ARTS
AND MUSIC INSTITUTION SO IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S COPYING FIGHT
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN CAPITOL
RECORDS THE LEGENDARY CAPITOL
RECORDS IT'S BASED IN.
IN MY DISTRICT AND I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO JOIN US --
TO TRACKS PROGRAM SO THIS IS A
UNIQUE PARTNERSHIP.
BETWEEN THE DISTRICT IN CAPITOL
RECORDS --
COMPTON UNIFIED OFFERS AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM THAT TEACHES
STUDENTS ABOUT CAREERS WITHIN
THE MUSIC INDUSTRY.
VIA AN IN PERSON SEMINAR WITH
RECORD EXECUTIVES IN PROVIDING
AN INVALUABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE STUDENTS TO LEARN FIRST HAND
ABOUT THE INNER WORKINGS OF A
MODERN RECORD LABEL.
AND THEY HELP THE STUDENTS LEARN
THE BUSINESS OF MUSIC ALONG WITH
IMPORTANT SKILLS THAT ARE
TRANSFERABLE INTO ANY FIELD.
INCLUDING CRITICAL THINKING
PRESENTATION COMPETENCE FINANCE
MARKETING HUMAN RESOURCES.
AND TEAM LEADERSHIP.
AND BONUS TRACKS EXEMPLIFIES
COMPANY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S COMMITMENT TO OF
ELEVATING THE ARTS IN SCHOOLS
AND EXPOSING STUDENTS TO A FULL
SPECTRUM OF CAREERS WITHIN THE
ARTS ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRIES.
HI SO WE HERE WE HAVE WITH US
TODAY -- OUR
BOARD PRESIDENT KILEY --
SUCH AS A READER WHO'S THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
I'M IN SEVERAL THE PORTRAITS
STE'S CHARLES DAVIS MARGIE
GARRETT CENTER MáS
SUPERINTENDENT AARON BRAWLEY.
AND ALSO DO MAKE IT HIGH SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL BLAINE WATSON AND THEN
FINALLY FROM CAPITOL RECORDS THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT BRIAN
NOLAN --
THEY'VE JUST BEEN BEEN FANTASTIC
I I WANT TO THANK CAPITOL
RECORDS --
SO MUCH FOR PROVIDING THIS
SPECIAL INSIDE A SPECIAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMP IN STUDENTS
TO LEARN ABOUT THE RECORD
INDUSTRY AND AND AND GET
EXPERIENCE SOME OF THE
EXCITEMENT.
OF WHAT IT'S LIKE BEING IN
ENTERTAINMENT CAREERS THIS IS A
MODEL THAT WE COULD USE AROUND
THE STATE I JUST WANT TO THANK
AN HONOR THE FOLKS FROM FROM --
BONUS TRACKS PROGRAM HERE ON THE
FLOOR TO MAKE CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TOO
WANT TO JOIN CENTER ALLEN
RECOGNIZING ACCOUNTING A FIGHT
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR THIS
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM.
I STAND BEFORE YOU AS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO BENEFIT FROM
MUSIC GROWING UP PLAY MUSIC FROM
THE TIME I WAS IN FOURTH GRADE
TILL.
HIGH SCHOOL AND I HAVE MANY OF
MY FRIENDS HAVE GONE ON TO BE
PROFESSIONAL MUSICIANS I SPENT.
TWENTY YEARS AS A INDEPENDENT
RECORD AND CLUB PROMOTER BEFORE
I ENTERED THE BODY POLITICS NEWS
THROUGH THAT EXPERIENCE THAT
PREPARED ME. FOR THIS INDUSTRY
HERE.
BECAUSE I ALWAYS FELT OF I CAN
FILL A CLUB OR CONCERT WITH
PEOPLE I COULD SURELY CONVINCE
HIM BY TO VOTE I WAS WRONG MANY
TIMES BUT WE'RE WE'RE STILL HERE
TODAY AND I WANT TO COMMEND THIS
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAPITOL RECORDS.
I'LL WORK WITH CAPITOL RECORDS
SOME THIRTYYEARS AGO ALONG WITH
MOTOWN AND RCA AN ERROR STIR.
AND THEY PROVIDED ME WITH GREAT
EXPOSURE TO NOT ONLY THE MUSIC
BUSINESS BUT LIFE IN GENERAL IN
INTERACTING WITH THE COMMUNITY
AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT TRANS
WERE AND WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO
HEAR AND I USED TO BREAK RECORD
FORMAT CLUBS TO SEE WHAT'S HOT
AND WHAT WASN'T.
HOT BUT I ALWAYS WANTED A CAREER
IN THE MUSIC BUSINESS I AM
REALLY ENVISIONED GOING TO WORK
FOR A LABEL BUT THE AT THE LATE
EIGHTIES THAT INDUSTRY QUICKLY
CHANGED AND AS I WAS HAVING A
MEETING WITH THEM EARLIER TODAY
I'M ENCOURAGED THAT.
THE INDUSTRY IS GOING BACK TO
REALLY REACH IN THE MARKETING OF
A YOUNG ARTIST SO I COMMEND THEM.
FOR ALL THE WORK BECAUSE THEY'RE
DOING NOW I STARTED.
THE GUARDIAN A JAZZ FELL SO
SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO AND WE'VE
HAD A A PATTERN OF HAVING YOUNG
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS OPEN THAT
ACT EVERY YEAR WILL HAVE A YOUNG
HIGH SCHOOL OR COLLEGE GROUP.
OPENING AT A SHOW AGAIN THIS
YEAR SO AGAIN THIS IS GOIN TO
BE BENEFICIAL FOR THEM RIGHT NOW
AND NOT ONLY RIGHT NOW BUT IN
THE FUTURE SO.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU FOR THE SCHOOL BOARD'S
VISION IN THIS AREA.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD THANK
YOU SENATOR ALLEN AND WELCOME TO
THE SCHOOL BOARD AND CAPITOL
MUSIC GROUP HERE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
WE WERE
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH OUR PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
[inaudible]
AND AND WE'RE NOW MOVING THE
INTRODUCTION AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL ONE FORTY NINE
ONE FIFTY ONE FIFTY ONE AND
SENATE BILL.
ONE FIFTY TWO THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
THEIR MCGUIRE IF I CAN ACTUALLY
TO COME UP HERE TO THE ROSTRUM
WILL MOVE TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AS CENTER
LAY THAT MAKES HER WAY TOWARD
GAS WE LIKE TO BE A WELCOME THE
IN THE LEADER'S CHARTER SCHOOL
FROM CENTER MORALES DISTRICT
IT'S GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE PLEASE
.
CLEARLY VALUE PREPARE TO TAKE UP.
I AM MR SECTOR PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION SEVEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
LABOR TE FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS AS CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS A
WOMAN A MOTHER A DAUGHTER A
SISTER AND A WIFE.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL RESOLUTION SENATE
RESOLUTION NUMBER.
SEVEN SR SEVEN COMMEMORATES THE
FORTY SIXTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU
ROE VERSUS WADE DECISION WHICH
AFFIRM THAT EVERY WOMAN HAS THE
RIGHT TO CONTROL HER
REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS.
AND DECIDE FOR HERSELF NGUYEN
AND WITH HOME TO HAVE CHILDREN
AND HOW MANY TO HAVE.
THAT DECISION HAS BEEN A
CORNERSTONE IN THE WOMEN'S
EQUALITY MOVEMENT AND ITS HELP
ADVANCE WOMEN'S ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY IN THE SOCIAL
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC LIFE.
OF OUR STATE AND COUNTRY.
TODAY ONE IN FOUR WOMEN IN THE
UNITED STATES WILL ACCESS
ABORTION SERVICES BY THE AGE OF
FORTY FIVE NATIONAL PEER
REVIEWED STUDIES INCREASINGLY
SHOW THAT ABORTION IS A SAFE
PROCEDURE.
DESPITE THE SAFETY AND NEED FOR
CONTINUED ACCESS TO ABORTION
SERVICES ROE VERSUS WADE IS IN
SERIOUS JEOPARDY OF BEING
OVERTURNED.
AND FURTHER A ROAD DUE TO THE
FACT THAT SOME STATES CONTINUE
TO PASS LEGISLATION THAT CREATES
BARRIERS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
FOR WOMEN.
THE RECENT APPOINTMENTS OF TO US
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES THAT ARE
LIKELY NOT SUPPORTIVE OF WOMEN'S
RIGHT A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE
HAS FURTHER DEMONSTRATED THE
DANGER THAT ROE VERSUS WADE
FACES.
LET'S BE CLEAR THESE FIGHTS ARE
NOT NEW.
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE
THIS HISTORIC DECISION HAS BEEN
UNDER CONSTANT ATTACK BUT THOSE
ATTACKS HAVE GAINED A NEW
NASTINESS AN ANTI WOMAN TONE
UNDER THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
THAT IS WHY IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT CALIFORNIA STANDS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ROE VERSUS
WADE.
S. R. SEVEN HIGHLIGHTS THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REMAINS
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING AND
ADVANCING.
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
NOW AND INTO THE FUTURE MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR LEYVA MEMBERS WE
HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR WE DO SENATOR PAN AND
THEN SENATOR ALSO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS --
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS ARE
SEVEN AND RIGHTS COMMEMORATE
GENERATE TWENTY SECOND. NINETEEN
AT THE FORTY SIXTH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE LANDMARK DECISION ROE
VERSUS WADE.
ROE VERSUS WADE RECOGNIZES THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF EVERY
WOMEN TO CONTROL THE
REPRODUCTIVE LIVES AND THEIR BY
THE RIGHT TO DECIDE WIN IF AND
WITH WHOM TO HAVE CHILDREN.
PUTTING THESE LIFE ALTERING
DECISIONS IN THE HANDS OF THE
PERSON WHOSE LIVES ARE ALTERED
IS ABOUT FAIRNESS AND FREEDOM.
THIS PERSONAL DECISION SHOULD BE
BETWEEN A WOMAN AND HER POSITION
WITHOUT GOVERNMENT INTERFERENCE.
PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCH
CONSISTENTLY INFORMS US THAT
CONTROL OF ONE'S REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH THROUGH FAMILY PLANNING
INCLUDING ABORTION IS CRITICAL
FOR ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL WELL
BEING.
AND IT IS ESSENTIAL FOR WOMEN TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY.
IN THE POLITICAL ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL LIFE OF A DEMOCRACY.
THUS I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EVERY WOMAN'S FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT.
AS A CONFIRMED IN ROE VERSUS
WADE TO MAKE HER OWN DECISIONS
REGARDING HER PREGNANCY AND
COMMIT TO BALL THE ADVANCE
ACCESS TO SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
NEVER TONIGHT BUT THANK YOU
CENTER PAN SENATOR RAZA THE
FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF HIS
STAR. SEVEN FORTY SIX YEARS AGO
THIS LANDMARK LEGAL DECISION.
TOGETHER WITH THE WAR ON POVERTY
AND INCREASED CIVIL RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS RESHAPED
THE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
LANDSCAPE FOR POOR WOMEN IN
AMERICA.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH IS DIRECTLY
LINKED. TO OUR ABILITY TO ACCESS
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES.
AND TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
STRENGTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES POOR
WOMEN HAVE ALWAYS PARTICIPATED
IN THE LABOR FORCE IN HIGH
NUMBERS.
TODAY WOMEN REPRESENT 50% OF THE
WORK FORCE IN CALIFORNIA NEARLY
HALF OF ALL HOUSEHOLDS ARE
SUPPORTED BY BREAD WINNER
MOTHERS.
SO WAS TRUE FIFTY YEARS AGO ANY
DAY.
THE HEALTH OF OUR ECONOMY.
AND OUR COMMUNITIES IS DEPENDENT
ON THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND
FREEDOM OF ALL WOMEN THANK YOU
AND I YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION THINK HE'S MUCH MADAM
SENATOR WE HAVE TO OTHERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DISCUSS
AND DEBATE WE LIKE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR.
WIENER IN IN SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
NINETEEN IS FOR THE REST MISTER
PRESIDENT.
ON COLLEAGUES I RISE AS CHAIR OF
THE LGBT CAUCUS AND STRONG
SUPPORT ADDRESS OUR SEVEN ON THE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND JUSTICE.
OFTEN FOCUS ON PEOPLE WHO ARE --
HETEROSEXUAL --
THESEISSUES DEEPLY IMPACT THE
LGBT COMMUNITY --
AS WELL AND LGBT PEOPLE ARE ALSO
AND SIGNIFICANT NEED --
OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES
IMPACT THE RATE OF PREGNANCY
AMONG ALL THE TO USE --
IS QUITE HIGH --
SO SAYS IMPACTS.
EVERYONE.
I ALSO WANTED.
TO REALLY STRESS THAT RUBY
WEIGHED.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR SO MANY
ISSUES -- IT
IS SO IMPORTANT.
ENSURING THAT WOMEN CAN ACCESS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES AND
MAKE DECISIONS.
ABOUT THEIR OWN BODIES BECAUSE
HONESTLY IT'S NO ONE ELSE'S
BUSINESS --
BUT ROW ALSO HELPED LAY THE
GROUNDWORK. FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
PROTECTIONS. FOR LGBT PEOPLE ARE
MORE BROADLY.
ROE V. WADE REALLY ACKNOWLEDGES
THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT FOR EACH
OF US. TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
OUR OWN LIVES INSTEAD OF HAVING
OTHER PEOPLE EMPOWER.
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS FOR US AND
SO THE ASSAULT THAT WE'RE SEEING
TODAY AN ASSAULT THAT HAS
CONTINUED OVER THE DECADES AND
SEEMS TO GET.
MORE AND MORE INTENSE OVER TIME --
IS AN ASSAULT.
ON REPORT IT IS A BROADER
ASSAULTS ON ALL OF OUR CIVIL
RIGHTS -- WE
MUST NEVER GO BACK AND I IS AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER MEMBERS
THAT TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
CENTER NúMERO GOOD AFTERNOON
SIR.
ILL GET AFTERNOON SENATOR HOW
ARE YOU TODAY.
YEAH THE FIRST FIVE DIGITS
QUICKLY.
WANT TO REITERATE AS I HAVE
BEFORE.
I'M STAUNCHLY BELIEVE THAT --
I'M IN FAVOR.
OF PROTECTING OUR BABIES.
IN THE WOMB SO --
I I JUST DON'T SEE HOW WE CAN IN
LIFE WHETHER AT THE BEGINNING.
OR IN THE AIR --
AT THE END OF LIFE SO --
SPECIALLY HUMAN BEINGS CREATED
IN GOD'S IMAGE THANK YOU GUYS
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER NOW TO MADAME SENATOR
JACKSON'S.
IS THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES AS ONE OF THE
OLDER.
SENIOR MEMBERS I WANNA STAND AND
TALK ABOUT WHAT LIFE WAS LIKE
BEFORE ROE.
I WAS ACTUALLY IN COLLEGE.
AND I HAD A NUMBER OF FRIENDS.
WHO FOUND THEMSELVES WITH
UNWANTED UNINTENDED UNPLANNED
PREGNANCIES WHO?
WOULD GO DOWN TO TIJUANA.
AND AT THAT POINT HAVE WHAT WERE
THEN LIFE THREATENING PROCEDURES
TO END AN UNWANTED PREGNANCY.
IN FACT GOING BACK TO THE EARLY
NINETEEN HUNDREDS WHERE BEFORE I
WAS BORN CONTRARY TO WHAT SOME
MIGHT THINK.
AN ESTIMATED EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND ILLEGAL ABORTIONS WERE
PERFORMED ANNUALLY.
RESULTING IN BETWEEN EIGHT
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
WOMEN'S DEATHS A YEAR.
THESE WERE WOMEN WHO WERE OUR
DAUGHTERS OR SISTERS OR MOTHERS.
THESE ARE WOMEN WHO WERE SO
DESPERATE NOT TO HAVE ANOTHER
MOUTH TO FEED MANY OF THEM COULD
NOT FEED THE MILES THAT THEY HAD
ALREADY.
THAT THEY WERE WILLING TO GO
THROUGH WHAT WAS THEN A LIFE
THREATENING PROCEDURE
[inaudible]
NOW.
THOSE WHO DIDN'T I BY THE WAY
MANY WERE RENDERED STERILE BY
BOTCHED PROCEDURES SO THEY
COULDN'T HAVE CHILDREN.
EVEN WHEN AND IF AND WITH WHOM
THEY WANTED [inaudible]
TODAY ABORTION IS THE MOST
COMMON OUTPATIENT SURGICAL
PROCEDURE IT IS EIGHT TO TEN
TIMES SAFER.
THAN GIVING BIRTH.
BECAUSE WE HAVE MADE IT LEGAL.
BECAUSE WE HAVE RECOGNIZED THAT
THE DECISION WHETHER TO HAVE A
CHILD SHOULD BELONG TO THE WOMAN
ALONE OR IN CONSULTATION WITH
WHOM EVER.
SHE SO CHOOSES.
THIS IS A PERSONAL ISSUE.
I REMEMBER BACK IN THE DAYS WHEN
THE PHILOSOPHY OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
WAS LESS GOVERNMENT IS BETTER
GOVERNMENT.
TODAY.
THERE IS A POLICY THAT SUGGESTS
THAT WOMEN SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
MAKE.
THOSE MOST PERSONAL DECISIONS
WITHOUT GOVERNMENT INTERFERENCE.
I FIND THAT TO BE A A DISSONANCE
THAT IS VERY HARD. TO OF
OVERCOME.
TODAY ONE IN FOUR AMERICAN WOMEN
WILL HAVE AN ABORTION IN HER
LIFETIME.
I SUGGESTED PART OF THAT IS
BECAUSE WE DON'T MAKE.
RE OF BIRTH CONTROL ACCESSIBLE
THAT WE HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING TO
IMPROVE.
THE RELIABILITY OF BIRTH CONTROL
IN THE COURSE OF DECADES.
OF I DON'T KNOW TOO MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXCITED WHEN THEY FIND
THEMSELVES WITHIN UNPLANNED
UNWANTED PREGNANCY.
BUT IT IS THE CHOICE OF WOMEN TO
MAKE.
AND IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE WHEN THE
SUPREME COURT FOUND THAT THE
RIGHT. TO DECIDE INTO CHOOSE WAS
A RIGHT OF PRIVACY THE BELONG TO
EVERY WOMAN.
WE SAW WOMEN'S OPPORTUNITIES
INCREASE.
WOMEN WERE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR FUTURE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO ACT
INDEPENDENTLY THEY WERE ABLE TO
PURSUE THEIR DREAMS AND I SHOULD
JUST SAY THEY ARE SHOULD SAY.
PROBABLY EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
EVERY FEMALE IN THIS ROOM.
IT'S A CHOICE.
IF YOU DON'T WANT.
THE TERMINATE A PREGNANCY.
AFTER.
NO ONE'S MAKING IT BUT NOBODY
SHOULD BE FORCED TO CONTINUE A
PREGNANCY THAT IS ON WANTED AND
SO ON THIS FORTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY.
IT REMAINS IMPERATIVE THE PRO
CHOICE AMERICANS SEND A MESSAGE
TO CONGRESS AND THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT WE WILL NOT GO BACK TO THE
DAYS OF ILLEGAL ABORTION.
WHEN WOMEN WERE DYING OF SEPSIS?
WHEN CHILDREN WERE NOT LOVED AND
CARED FOR BECAUSE THEY WERE ON
WANTED?
TO A SAD STATE OF AFFAIRS BUT A
REAL ONE THE RESULT AT AGAIN IN
THOUSANDS OF DEATHS OF WOMEN ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS AND SO.
IN KEEPING WITH THE TRADITION OF
THE OLD DAYS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO A CONTINUATION.
A WHAT WE SAID BACK IN THE DAY
THAT ABORTION SHOULD BE LATE ARE
SHOULD BE SAFE.
LEGAL.
AND RARE.
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS WOULD
LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR MORLOCK MISTER SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THAT
LIFE IS BUILT [inaudible]
AND I'M THANKFUL THAT --
WOMEN ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO CRISIS
PREGNANCY CENTERS.
WHICH PROVIDE WOMEN WITH
PREGNANCY TESTING PRENATAL
VITAMINS PARENTING CLASSES AND
OTHER SERVICES.
AND THEY REPRESENT A FREE SPEECH
OPPORTUNITY AND WE SHOULD OPPOSE
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST NON
PROFITS THAT GIVES.
LIFE AFFIRMING OPTIONS TO WOMEN
FACING UNPLANNED PREGNANCIES THE
TOP ISSUE MISTER CHAIR MISTER
PRESIDENT WE WANT TO KEEP IT
RARE.
BUT AT LEAST THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS WE JUST THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU SIR.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
MICROPHONE UP THAT SENATOR
MITCHELL AND IT WILL TURN OVER
TO SENATOR LEYVA [inaudible] TO
CLOSE [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
TOP OF THE AFTERNOON TO YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I STAND AS
I DO EVERY YEAR IN FAVOR OF THE
RESOLUTION THAT COMMEMORATES THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE SUPREME COURT
RULING THIS YEAR THAN TO LAY
THIS S. R..
SEVEN BECAUSE I TOO AM IN FAVOR
OF PROTECTING CHILDREN.
AND MY VOTING RECORD --
ON THIS FLOOR PROVES THAT.
BECAUSE I VOTED TO SUPPORT
FUNDING GOING TO REDUCING THE
BLACK INFANT MORTALITY AND
MORBIDITY RATE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE HIGHEST IN
THE NATION.
I VOTED TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO ALL
CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
I CONTINUE TO VOTE TO GUARANTEE
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
ACTUALLY GET IT.
I VOTE TO SUPPORT --
AND MAKE SURE THAT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD CONTINUES TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SERVICES LIKE PREVENTIVE CANCER
SCREENING AND THE MYRIAD OF
SERVICES THEY PROVIDED MANY OF
OUR DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE.
IN MANY COMMUNITIES THAT --
PEOPLE ARE CHALLENGED TO FIND
THOSE VERY NECESSARY HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
AND TRAGICALLY IF I WERE A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS IN IN DC I
WOULD CERTAINLY VOTE TO IN THIS
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE CAL FRESH BENEFITS.
FEED.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN IN
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
I TOO AM IN FAVOR OF PROTECTING
CHILDREN.
AND MAKING SURE THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO THRIVE IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW THIS WE CAN --
NOT ONLY IS IT THE ANNIVERSARY
OF ROE V. WADE BUT WE
COMMEMORATED DR KING'S BIRTHDAY
YESTERDAY.
AND I'M SURE ALL OF US HAD
MARCHES AND FESTIVITIES ACROSS
OUR DISTRICTS.
AND I READ JUST THIS MORNING AT
THE MARCH A UNIQUE GROUP
PARTICIPATING.
IT WAS A GROUP OF ANTI CHOICE AT
THE KIDS WHO ARE HOLDING UP
SIGNS THAT SAID BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
SUGGESTING THAT ABORTION WAS THE
GREATEST THREAT TO BLACK
CHILDREN.
WELL AS A BLACK WOMAN I RESENT
THAT.
AS A BLACK MOTHER I RESENT THAT
AND THOSE STATISTICS CERTAINLY
DON'T BRING THAT BACK TO BEAR.
I'M NOT GONNA TAKE THE TIME TO
REMIND ALL OF YOU IN THIS ROOM
WHAT ARE THE LOOMING THREATS TO
BLACK CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT RESTING BELIEVE TRUST AND
BELIEVE.
IT'S NOT A BLACK WOMAN
EXERCISING HER FUNDAMENTAL.
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED RIGHT
TO CHOOSE.
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT IN WIND
BRINGS A CHILD INTO THE WORLD.
SO FOR ALL THESE REASONS ONCE
AGAIN I PROUDLY STAND IN SUPPORT.
OF THE S. R..
SEVEN THANK YOU SENATOR.
IF WE CAN SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR LAST CALL FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
HEARING C. NINE CENTER LEYVA YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALAN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BILL.
I WERE JUST.
NO BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROVE [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL.
BY WITH SOME.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON BY.
JONES [inaudible]
NOPE [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
NO AMBERG.
BY WHY KATHY [inaudible]
BY WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
NOPE.
ICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS NINE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ADVANCING AND
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO BE
RECOGNIZING INDIVIDUALS WHO
SUBMITTED THEIR ADJOURN IN
MEMORIES. TO THE PRO TEM'S
OFFICE. TO BE ABLE TO START OUT
WITH THAT GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER THE SENATOR STONE.
SEVEN MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
DURING THE SENATE AND THE MEMORY
OF MISTER BOB MORRISON ACCLAIM
BUILDER AN ARTIST WHO DIED ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY FIRST OF HIS
HOME NEAR TO MACULA.
HE WAS EIGHTY FIVE YEARS OLD
BORN IN ARKANSAS BOB CAME TO
CALIFORNIA WITH HIS FAMILY
DURING THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
HE WORKED IN THE STEEL INDUSTRY
BEFORE DISCOVERING TO MACULA IN
THE LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES WHILE
ON HORSEBACK.
RIDING FROM CALEXICO TO
RIVERSIDE FOLLOWING THE ONE
PARTIES TODAY AND THE TRAIL.
HE LIKE THE SPELL THIS LIKE THE
SMALL TOWN FEEL OF TO MACULA
MOVED HIS FAMILY TO THE REGION.
AND THE REGION WAS LUCKY TO HAVE
HIM AND HIS TALENTS.
BOB IN A GROUP DEDICATED TO
PRESERVING THE WESTERN FEEL OF
TO MACULA GOT TOGETHER TO BUILD
THE BUTTERFIELD SQUARE A RETAIL
COMPLEX HE USED --
BILL BUILDING MATERIALS THAT
WERE COLLECTED OVER FIVE YEARS
FROM OLD BARNS IN OLD BUILDINGS.
EVENTUALLY BOB BILL FOR OTHER
BUILDINGS IN OLD TOWN TEMECULA
ALL OF THEM MADE OF THE MATURITY
COLLECTED FROM ACROSS THE WEST.
THE BUILDINGS TO RETURN THIS TO
THE AREA AND HELP PRESERVE THE
COLORFUL HISTORY.
OF THE MACULA SPECIALLY THE OLD
TOWN AREA.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WHEN THE
CITY CORPORATE IT TO MAKE IT WAS
THE OVERWHELMING CHOICE FOR THE
NAME OF THE NEW CITY WITH RANCH
CALIFORNIA.
A DISTANT SECOND.
JUST TEN YEARS AGO OLD TOWN
TEMECULA AS ENVISIONED BY BOB
MORRIS WAS RENOVATED WITH WOODEN
SIDEWALKS AN ANTIQUE STREET
LAMPS TO THE HISTORIC DISTRICT
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN OLD TOWN
TEMECULA.
BELIEVE ME IT'S A GREAT PLACE TO
COME AND VISIT.
TODAY THE OLD TOWN TEMECULA IS A
THRIVING TOURIST DISTRICT WITH
DOZENS OF RESTAURANTS CLUBS NEW
HOTELS IN A VIBRANT NIGHTLIFE.
LET'S JUST SA THAT BOB WASN'T A
BIG FAN OF THIS NEW DEVELOPMENT
HOWEVER MOST OF WHAT BOB BUILT
REMAINS EXCEPT BUTTERFIELD
SQUARE.
HIS FIRST PROJECT WHICH WAS TORN
DOWN LAST YEAR TO MAKE ROOM FOR
A BRAND NEW HOTEL.
THE FACT THE EFFORTS OF BOB
MORRIS ENSURED THAT THE COLORFUL
HISTORY TO MACULA WHICH COULD
HAVE BEEN WIPED OUT.
WILL BE EXPLORED AND ENJOYED FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME. TO MAKE A
LOS THE FOUNDING FATHER WHEN BOB
PASSED IN MAY BE GONE BUT HIS
LEGACY LIVES ON AND IS ENJOYED
BY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE EVERY DAY
IN THE CITY.
HE LOVED AND HELP BUILD THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES TO MAKE A LIST
FOUNDING FATHERS MISTER BOB
MORRIS.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARDS WE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATOR DRAWS SO I THINK YOU HAD
AN ATTORNEY MEMORY.
YES PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS I ASK YOU TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF LEO ESTRADA.
HE PASSED AWAY ON NOVEMBER THIRD
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HE WAS AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR EMERITUS OF
URBAN PLANNING.
AT UCLA'S LE LUSKIN SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR FORTY YEARS
BEFORE HIS RETIREMENT.
HE DEVOTED HIS TIME AND TALENT
TO RESEARCH AND TEACHING NEW
GENERATIONS OF URBAN PLANNERS.
FOR THE TEXAS NATIVE WHO FIRST
ARRIVED AT UCLA IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN HIS CAREER WAS
ALSO MARKED FROM THE BEGINNING
BY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT ACTIVISM AND
GIVING BACK TO THE COMMUNITY.
HE WAS AN INSPIRING TEACHER AND
MENTOR TO NOT ENDLESS NUMBER OF
UCLA STUDENTS.
AND A ROLE MODEL TO MANY LATINOS
AND MINORITY STUDENTS.
AS A BRILLIANT DEMOGRAPHER HE
WAS ALSO INSTRUMENTAL IN
CONFRONTING GERRYMANDERING AND
GIVING UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES EQUAL REPRESENTATION
IN CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND BASICALLY HE TAUGHT US AND
GAVE US THE TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO
REPRESENT OUR COMMUNITIES IN --
ESPECIALLY IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS IS STRONG RELATIONSHIP
WITH LOCAL LEADERS POSITION TO
HIM AS A PILLAR IN OUR COMMUNITY
HE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY HIS
BELOVED WIFE OF THIRTY SIX YEARS.
EVIL LESS THEIR TWO SONS AND
THEIR MUCH BELOVED GRANDSON
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING
MISTER ESTRADA AND SEND IN OUR
HOW HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES. TO
HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO CENTER
HERTZBERG BRIEFLY --
MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO JOIN
IN WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
I TO HAVE HAVE KNOWN ON
PROFESSOR SHRADDHA FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND I REMEMBER IN THE
NINETIES I CAN'T REMEMBER
EXACTLY WHEN.
WHEN YOU GET AS OLD AS ME CAN'T
REMEMBER EXACTLY WHEN BUT?
BUT WHEN WE WERE INVOLVED IN THE
CHICANOS UCLA IN THE HUNGER
STRIKES.
AND I WAS REPRESENTING ALL THE
STUDENTS WHO GOT ARRESTED FOR
TAKEN OVER THIS THE FACULTY
CENTER AND HE WAS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT COMMON VOICE WHO MAY
READ ON THE ONE HAND THE
STRENGTH OF VISION AND VALUES.
FOR THE CHICANO STUDIES
DEPARTMENT BUT GUIDED THE
PROCESS TO BECAUSE CONCLUSION SO
THAT UCLA NOW HAS SUCH A
DEPARTMENT THE HUNGER STRIKE WAS
SUCCESSFULLY RESOLVED.
ALL THE STUDENTS WERE LED OUT OF
JAIL AND ARMORED UPWARD AND
LEONA STRAW THE JUST ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF EXTRAORDINARY
LEADERSHIP IN ADDITION TO IS
ALREADY MENTIONED WITH REGARD TO
HAVE MY AND DURING HIS MEMORY.
FONDLY.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
SENATOR RAZA PLEASE BRING HIS
SAME FORTS WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED.
THEIR NúMERO I BELIEVE IN A
JOURNEY MEMORY.
RECEIVED HIGH CERTAINLY DO THANK
YOU.
AT MADAME PRESIDENT.
AND I'M FELLOW MEMBERS --
I RISE TO THE RANGER IN THE
MEMORY OF DON --
JOHN ITEM HE WAS BORN IN LOS
ANGELES IN NINETEEN THIRTY THREE
GROWING UP IN LOS ANGELES.
AND HE ATTENDED PEPPERDINE
UNIVERSITY WHERE HE RECEIVED HIS
DEGREE IN BUSINESS I HAD A GREAT.
TIME IN BOTH BUSINESS AND
CHRISTIAN MINISTRY FOR OVER
SIXTY YEARS HE LIVED AND
REDLANDS AREA AND HE BECAME A
GOOD FRIEND OF MINE AND EVEN A
CLOSE MENTOR.
OFTEN OFFERING ME ADVICE WHEN I
DIDN'T ASK OUT TO BE REALLY GOOD
ADVICE WHICH I DID TAKE --
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE HE
AND HIS BROTHER --
NOT ONLY OPEN ANOTHER A BILL
BUSINESSES BUT THEY MADE SOME
MONEY SO THEY OPEN UP --
TO CARE FOR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES --
AND OTHER MEDICAL CHALLENGES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA HE ALSO HELP
START A CHRISTIAN COLLEGE AS YOU
CAN TELL YOU IS A MAN OF THE
STRONG.
IN HIS CHRISTIAN FAITH AND HE
HAD -- MANY --
OTHER CHARITIES WHICH HE LOVED
TO BE ABLE TO HELP HIS COMMUNITY
SURVIVED BY HIS LOVELY WIFE RUTH.
AND HIS CHILDREN JACK DAVE SALLY.
IN GM.
AND BOB AS WELL AS TWENTY THREE
GRANDCHILDREN --
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
IN OUR JOURNEY --
TODAY IN SESSION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU CENTER WERE
FORWARD SO WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE HIM SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
IN MEMORY OF MY MANA HARM
COMPANIES IN OTHER WAYS KNOWN IN
HIS COMMUNITY AS PAUL PAUL NOT
ONLY GREW UP IN ARCADIA HE WAS
ALSO AN ALUMNUS OF ARCADIA HIGH
AND THIS IS A PACIFIC UNIVERSITY
MY ALMA MATER.
HE OFTEN TRAVELED FOR WORK IN
HIS ROLE AS CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER OF COUPLES FIRST
MICROFINANCE BANK WHICH PROVIDES
MICHAEL LOANS TO THE POOR THE
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
IN PARTICULAR YOU WOMEN IN
AFGHANISTAN.
PAUL WAS AMONG THE FOR
INDIVIDUALS KILLED THIS LAST
WEEK IN A SUICIDE BOMBING THAT
TOOK PLACE IN KABUL AFGHANISTAN
ON MONDAY JANUARY FOURTEENTH.
I STAND HERE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE
HIS MEMORY ALONG WITH THREE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS KILLED THAT
DAY AND A HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
OTHERS THAT WERE WOUNDED.
TODAY I AM REMINDED AS A
MILITARY MEMBER MYSELF JUST THE
DANGERS THAT OUR FAMILIES FACE
WHEN THEY GO OVERSEAS TO FIGHT
FOR OUR FREEDOMS AND OUR COUNTRY.
AND THOSE THAT GO OUT TO HELP
LIKE THIS GENTLEMAN WHO IS THERE
JUST OFFERING HIS SERVICES --
SO PAUL WAS A THOUGHT POINT
GIVING PERSON WHO ALWAYS HELD IN
HIS COMMUNITY HE WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED BY HIS FRIENDS FAMILIES.
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY ONCE
AGAIN HE PASSED ON JANUARY
FOURTEENTH LEAVING BEHIND HIS
WIFE THREE CHILDREN AND TWO
SIBLINGS AND HIS FATHER SO I
CLOSING AS MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE
BRING HIS SAME FORWARDS WE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED SENATOR
WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT.
ARE COLLEAGUES --
TODAY I RAW ISN'T GOING BY --
THE SENATOR GREAT --
SADNESS REQUESTED THE SENATE
ADJOURNED.
IN MEMORY OF DIANE OLSEN.
THAT'S THE WAY ON WEDNESDAY
JANUARY SIXTEENTH.
MS OLSON AND HER WAYS ARE ROBIN
TYLER WERE --
THE FIRST PLAINTIFFS IN THE
LAWSUIT --
THAT ULTIMATELY RESULTED IN A
MARRIAGE EQUALITY RULING FROM
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT --
AFTER THEIR MARRIAGE IN JUNE --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT MANY YEARS
BEFORE --
THAT A FULL DAY --
DIANA ROBIN WERE ALREADY
PROMINENT FIGURES IN THE FREEDOM
TO MARRY MOVEMENT.
I THEIR RESOLVE TO FIGHT FOR
MARRIAGE EQUALITY WAS GALVANIZED --
WHEN ROBIN RETIRED?
AND HER UNION REFUSE TO EXTEND
SPOUSAL BENEFITS I TO DIANE
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT LEGALLY
MARRIED.
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
AND ON EVERY VALENTINE'S DAY
THERE AFTER --
THE TWO WOULD GO TO THE BEVERLY
HILLS COURTHOUSE AND APPLY FOR A
MARRIAGE LICENSE AND OF COURSE
THEY WERE DENIED REPEATEDLY.
UNTIL THEY WEREN'T AND I SO --
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR GLORIA
ALLRED ON BEHALF OF THE COUPLE
FILED A LAWSUIT FOR THE RIGHT TO
MARRY IN CALIFORNIA --
WHICH EVENTUALLY RESULTED IN THE
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT RULING
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT IN FAVOR OF MARRIAGE
EQUALITY.
BOB ON THAT DAY --
JUNE SIXTEENTH TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT IN FRONT OF CAMERAS
BROADCASTING ALL OVER THE WORLD.
OF THE COUPLE WERE MARRIED IN A
CEREMONY THE LATER REFERRED TO
AS THEIR QUOTE BIG FAT JEWISH
LESBIAN WEDDING --
THROUGH HER EXPERIENCE AND HER
ADVOCACY --
DIANE OLSEN HELPED PAVE THE WAY
FOR MARRIAGE EQUALITY NOT ONLY
IN CALIFORNIA --
PREFER BUT FOR OUR ENTIRE NATION --
FOR THIS AMONG MANY OTHER
REASONS --
SHE WILL BE DEARLY REMEMBER.
HI DAN I DON'T WANT TO SAY WHAT
IS A HERO --
WALL SHE HAS PASSED FROM THIS
WORLD.
HER LEGACY IS A MORAL.
AND SO COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF DIANE OLSEN.
THANK YOU SIR WIENER PLEASE
BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE
MAY BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
MEMBERS CENTER HELP WHAT PURPOSE
YOU RISE PURPOSES OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS PLEASE PRESIDENT
THANK YOU A COLLEAGUES IF YOU'D
LIKE AFTER UPON ADJOURNMENT THE
THERE'S A CONTINUED RECEPTION
INTO ELEVEN FOR DR CARSON HE HAS
MANY OF HIS WORKS ON DISPLAY.
AS WELL AS SOME VIDEOS THAT YOU
COULD --
CERTAINLY ENJOY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU CENTER HILL.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
DISTANCE CLEAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL.
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WE MADE WE YOU
VERY MUCH.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM HAVE A GREAT DAY MEMBERS